welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of secret
Invasion episode one no one is safe and
in this world oblies and deceit and
creepy girls with bouncy balls survival
depends on our ability to observe these
things closely for subtle nuances
missable details hidden agendas and good
old-fashioned Marvel Easter eggs so
let's dive back into the scroll search
and break down this episode frame by
frame for everything you might have
missed a quick announcement new rock
stars is now three channels this channel
for the Easter egg breakdowns like
you're watching right now and the break
room which is our new home of our inside
Marvel secret Invasion after shows and
also the Deep dive for the special film
analyzes for me subscribe to all three
and support us with this scroll inspired
shirt at nerd riot.shot okay the opening
Marvel Studios title card does not use
the flashy swoop through the letters
with the iconic MCU moments that we
typically see there's no time for that
this isn't about the Avengers and their
boom booms it's about the Stark
realities of living in a world where no
hero can be trusted Moscow present day
the same title card location type base
as we saw in Captain America Civil War
and a black widow stylistically
internally the producers of the series
are going for spycraft and globetrotting
political drama and by present day
Marvel Studios executive Jonathan
Schwartz confirmed that the show takes
place after She-Hulk so in the MCU
timeline we're looking at like late 2025
or maybe early 2026 but Marvel has
proven time and time again that they
cannot agree on exact dates for these
titles agent Everett Ross or who we
think is him takes a call after being
introduced as a CIA agent in Captain
America Civil War he returned in Black
Panther and then again in Black Panther
will kind of forever where we learned
his ex-wife is Cia director Val he
committed Espionage for the wakandans
and got arrested but Okoye broke him
free but since this is a scroll imposter
version of Ross presumably the real Ross
could be hiding in wakanda or Ross might
have been taken and he's in a scroll
fracking pod somewhere I don't think the
implication is that the whole character
of Ross every time we've seen him has
been a scroll but rather this imposter
has filled in some time recently while
Ross has been M.I.A this kind of brick
tunnel is a classic spy setting perhaps
inspired by the 1949 Orson Welles film
The Third Man series director Ali Salin
confirmed to us in an interview that
films like the this we're part of his
inspiration go back even further like uh
the third man oh yeah the classics right
sure and because the show is the secret
invasion is about uh trust and uh
suspicion and identity I always go back
to the conversation hopeless
conversation there is a sense that Nick
Fury which you'll see in later episodes
sort of evolves into a lone classic
American Western Gunslinger uh which is
again a little different
um than we've ever seen him before and
so we started to look at classic
American westerns like the Searchers and
even um Unforgiven Ross tosses his phone
he doesn't want to be tracked and he
pulls a firearm from his ankle the gun
he'll use to plug poor Prescott we hear
press God's voice here imagine a world
where information can be trusted not
very hard is it
Richard Dormer and Barrick dungarian the
late me Lord from Game of Thrones which
is really perfect for this croaky True
Believer rant this speech outlines the
whole who do you trust theme that ran
throughout Brian Michael bendis's 2009
Marvel crossover event that this series
is based on but specifically Prescott is
talking to who he thinks is Ross and how
lately a guy like Ross cannot trust even
someone like his ex-wife Val the CIA
director I think Prescott is hinting
that Val could be a scroll without
realizing that the guy he's talking to
actually is but while we're playing this
game of skull search I think the CIA
director Julie Louis-Dreyfus is a very
good option of someone who could be a
scroll Prescott references the hazy
distinction between real news outlets
and Fringe conspiracy websites something
that we saw explored in Spider-Man no
way home with Jay Jonah Jameson's Daily
Bugle Outlet which by the end of that
film was live streaming in Times Square
as Ross walks up to the building you can
see the windows on the second floor are
papered over with newspaper to hide from
surveillance and to pin on one's
favorite conspiracy Clash Prescott's
computer inside shows ukn24 news I don't
believe that's a real news service but
might be something like the BBC or news
from the Kremlin since this is Russia
and Russia doesn't normally allow
residents to access Western internet so
Prescott would need to have his own
Uplink if that's the case there's a
classic Pepe Sylvia research wall
because this is what I do best I'm going
to break down everything on this we see
news clippings about a Colombian X Rebel
politician searching with young voters
the headline above says that he's a
nationalist and this is already telling
us something's up because in Latin
America and in most places in the world
young voters don't typically support
far-right nationalists but Latin America
left-wingers and socialists are
typically more popular with the onions
so this tells us that both sides of this
political shift are really being
orchestrated by squirrels and there's a
lot more than a handful of Scrolls on
Earth then a redacted document beneath
showing that same bearded man who is
just on the computer screen and you can
make out the word treadstone which is
the name of a Black Ops project in the
porn identity films yellow Post-it notes
reading Bogota Terror connected to Heist
who is a Target and beside that to the
left Argentine group claims to be
responsible Prescott later explains that
it was an Argentinian terrorist group
who attacked Bogota resulting in a
political shift in that country followed
by an attack in the Philippines and then
a mass shooting in Munich and we see on
the board an explosion in London so
rather than independent groups he says
that they are all connected one group of
squirrels seeking to destabilize the
political regimes on Earth chaos
and that's only the beginning in a word
chaos there's also a headline about an
embassy attack and quote theft of
confidential items this placent Heist
mentioned might mean the scrolls are
taking tissue and other materials in
their plot to create super scroll
Warriors which in the comics are
squirrels that can also mimic the powers
in addition to the appearance of the
enhanced individuals that they morph
into and in the trailer we saw a
container with cull obsidian on the
label this could have been one of those
stolen items Prescott also has a Russian
translation book on the table showing
that he has followed this city by city
and has to learn the new language
everywhere he goes and I think before he
dies this proves he's not a scroll if he
took their minds and memories he would
know how to speak their languages
already Ross says the atmosphere has
been tense yeah because he's a squirrel
and adapted to a new Global atmosphere
we're on to you Prescott says started 30
years ago when the Scrolls found Earth
Carol Danvers and Nick Fury promise to
find them a new planet yeah he's
recapping the events of the 2019 Captain
Marvel film which ended with Carol
Danvers leaving Earth with scroll
refugees in the year 1995. since then we
know Fury has been working with
squirrels on Earth with Talos and his
wife sore and filling in for Fury and
Maria Hill and Spider-Man Far From Home
Prescott asks then where is Fury he's on
saver saber is a space station that we
see in the trailer for the Marvels and
it might be the same
decision that Fury was on with several
squirrels in the post-credit scene for
Far From Home saber is based on the peak
that's the space station of Sword in the
comics Sword and the MCU has been seen
in one Division and under the leadership
of Tyler Hayward was focused more on
terrestrial anomalies but with Monica
Rambo involved now it might have shifted
back to his astronaut projects which
seems to be the case in the Marvel's
trailer Prescott hands Ross a hollow
deck immediately we see a scroll face
beam up and notice that Martin Freeman
looks outward over the display since
this girl already knows what he's about
to see Prescott's seeds through Ross's
and he tackles the chokesman
but Ross shoots him through the chest
and he calls Maria Hill for an
extraction and for Roz to show up in her
card's computer display as the actual
agent Ross tells us that she either knew
that he would be there and the Scrolls
had infiltrated this unit without her
knowing and that poor Marie Hill was
doomed by the end of this episode or
just that squirrels can bypass whatever
voice ID and unique phone that Ross
would have set up with Hill ahead of
time Ross flees his tail through this
blue lit Rave with the dancers doing
that same fist pump that you know Zemo
did when he became that Meme in the
Falcon the Winter Soldier then on the
rooftop it's some splashy purple
lighting mixing it with the green tones
of the night sky to give off the green
and purple color palette that we see in
the main titles scroll skin is of course
green and their bruises and blood show
up as The Color Purple this in roster
doesn't make the jump and we learned
that his pursuer was Talos in Disguise
Ross dies a scroll bleeding out on the
street just as Maria Hill's Shadow
nearly touches him foreshadowing her own
death this way at the end of the episode
Tommy actually asked the director if
Ross was meant to be seen as a squirrel
the entire time we've known him or not I
think all will be revealed okay yeah all
will be revealed is how my uncle signs
off all his emails oh really a little
ominous yeah yeah like what does this
mean what are you gonna reveal to us I
might steal it hmm so for example the
series will answer that question I think
if you pay to get Martin Freeman in your
series he doesn't just show up in one
episode like Julie Louis-Dreyfus and Don
Cheadle both showed up twice in two
different episodes each on Falcon winner
soldier visited navrio originally shot
scenes for two episodes in Hawkeye
though they cut the earlier one with
young echo in the Karate Dojo so I will
think we'll see some form of Everett
Ross again now it was confirmed that the
opening titles were generated by AI a
company called method Studios according
to the director I would have preferred
if a human artist or animator were paid
to do this work especially since Marvel
held this all the way to June you could
say Marvel might have done this on
purpose to start us off with false
non-human imagery I don't know I think
they just wanted to save a buck this
show ain't about technology it's about
xenophobia but hey I'm just gonna point
out a few of these details that they fed
this AI script to synthesize and to
welcome our new computer overlords we
see the destruction of the scroll
Homeworld of skrillos a Serene field
explodes in volcanic eruption followed
by the doomed Planet as spacious ships
depart on the right this is what made
the scroll people so diasporatic then a
single figure maybe the first scroll on
Earth with the scroll craft floating
overhead reminds us visually of Peter
Quill when he got abducted by the
ravagers in 1988 the city of New York as
scroll ships float overhead out of sight
with a Green Wave spreading through the
buildings then Nick Fury is still
wearing his eye patch here standing
inside of a scroll ship it looks like
then people walking in front of the
Kremlin I think it does look like the
architecture of moscow's Red Square as
their faces turn to scroll green then
members of law enforcement shifted into
Scrolls then a fire raging through
Moscow foreshadowing the bomb at the end
of this episode then the clock of
Elizabeth Tower aka Big Ben glowing
green as the hand spins rapidly then we
get our first look at the scroll Council
humans and positions of authority as
they scroll in a suit shifts back into a
human form presumably many world leaders
are actually Scrolls then interesting
shot we see the Green Cloud hovering
over the White House but unlike the
other famous governmental landmarks
which become the color green the White
House remains white still unaffected by
the scroll influence I think president
ritzen might be one world leader who is
still as of now on crowd update but that
also makes them more vulnerable in a way
and then a chessboard for telling Nick
and Maria's chess game later on this
episode and here a bishop shifts into a
queen and then into a king the idea
being that Faith leaders queens and
kings all cannot be trusted right now
Fury thinks he's playing Cold War era
chess but really he's playing chess
where all of his opponents pawns have
somehow made it to the other side of the
board and have now leveled up into
pieces that can move however the hell
they want and we see how gravic jumps
the rank from a bishop like a lieutenant
all the way to the top as the king don't
forget the queen who we could see as
Gaia is technically the most powerful
piece on a chessboard thank you to
betterhelp for sponsoring this video
movies and TVs can be great escapism but
when it's time to face things head on
better help is here to help better help
is the world's largest therapy service
and it's 100 online with better help you
can tap into a network of over 30 000
licensed and experienced therapists who
can help you with a wide range of issues
to get started just answer a few
questions about what you're looking for
from therapy and what your preferences
are better help will then match you with
a therapist from their Network that's
right for you after that talk to your
therapist however you feel comfortable
whether it's via text chat phone or
video call you can message your
therapist at any time and schedule live
sessions when it's convenient for you if
your therapist isn't the right fit for
any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge Better
Health gives you the same level of
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom picked for you
with scheduling flexibility and at a
more affordable price get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com new
rockstars that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com Slash new
rockstars for 10 off your first month of
therapy a beam of blinding light pierces
the forest and the silhouette of Nick
Fury steps off the ship the blinding
light reminds us a lot of Steven
Spielberg's lighting and close
encounters to the Third Kind Fury
immediately doubles over when seen in
pain from his knee he's not as spry as
he used to be and adjusting to Earth's
gravity as opposed to the space station
isn't as easy on this old timer Fury
wears a knit cap and a coat pretty much
the same clothes that scroll Ross did I
know it's just cold but you know this
show just doesn't really want us to
trust anybody most importantly Fury is
not wearing his signature eye patch in
an interview with Vanity Fair Samuel
Jackson said the patch is part of who
strong Nick Fury was but now his new is
part of his vulnerability now you can
look at it and see he's not this
perfectly instructable person in Maria
Hill's safe house there's a poster for
Island art at the Brixton Community
Center Brixton is part of London so the
safe house might have been set up by
fallsworth in the MI6 on the rooftop
Talos cultivates a sento milka a scroll
Sky plant he says planted by Soren who
carry these seeds around Taylor says
that it's adapted to this planet a
metaphor for how the Scrolls have
adapted to Earth and prefer it as their
home as opposed to some new Homeworld
that might not even be out there now the
word Santo is Spanish for Saint or holy
or sacred and milka is a Hindu name
meaning Desiring Union or wishes Unity
so together we get two cultures coming
together two electric company together
sacred Unity which is what Talos and
Soren wanted between humans and Scrolls
Fury and Talos press their heads
together a scroll gesture of endearment
that we saw Talos and Soren do in
Captain Marvel and Taylor says but after
the blip you were different we only
briefly saw Fury post split at Tony
Stark's funeral on Avengers end game
perhaps being so freaked out by thanos's
attack has turned Fury's attention to
Cosmic threats and that's why he's on
saber we learned Talos was kicked off
The Scroll Council and graphic now leads
it and he set up his base in one of
Russian's abandoned nuclear plants many
of which are off the books we learned
that squirrels can withstand radiation
probably because their shape shifting
occurs on a molecular level as we learn
in Captain Marvel which would allow
their cells to resist neutrons firing
through them we learned that squirrels
are used in American taken from an AAR
group Americans against Russia to
detonate a bomb for materials taken from
Kazakhstan to start a war between Russia
and the United States a plot that we saw
in Tom Clancy's Espionage Thriller the
sum of all beers James Rhodes returns
last scene in the back of the Winter
Soldier now briefing U.S president
ritzen played by German Mulroney a
perfect pick for a show about face
blindness considering the running bit of
everyone confusing him with Dylan
McDermott this is a picture of my face
who am I Dylan McDermott or Derman
Malone in Captain America Brave New
World Harrison Ford has been announced
to play U.S president Thaddeus Ross so
something's going to go down with
President britson on their West Wing
Style walk and talk they pass portraits
of U.S presidents Harry Truman Ulysses S
Grant George Washington I think that's
Dwight Eisenhower by the flowers James
Buchanan Jimmy Carter Richard Nixon and
Ronald Reagan they aren't in any
particular order and we just give Gerald
Ford an actual order of succession there
but the idea is how far back would an
alien infiltration have gone how many of
these guys were actually human the
secret Invasion Comics don't shy away
from politics both Barack Obama and John
McCain were depicted to Scrolls on TV
screens and it's interesting we don't
see any presidents past Reagan because
as with the West Wing the modern era of
the MCU takes place in a separate
historical timeline with different
presidents like through 2016 in the MCU
continuity the president was Matthew
Ellis who was last seen in Iron Man 3.
Fury's nighttime stroll takes some path
to food truck with the Cyrillic letters
for Shawarma fitting that this founder
of the Avengers would grab a bite of
their favorite food Fury passes a kiss
and couple and the woman looks at him
this is one of the people that gravic
turns into later so all these people
look at fury on this walk therefore are
squirrels watching his every move this
idea of kissing to stay hidden in plain
sight was actually a move by Steve
Rogers and Natasha Romanov and Winter
Soldier kiss me what public displays of
affection make people very uncomfortable
yes I do
yet this girl doesn't care if Yuri looks
at her because gravic knows that his
plot is too far along to stop a ball
bounces out in the street and a girl
stares at Fury the same girl and ball
emulated by graphic later this raises
some red flags and it's the same
rightful alien suspicion that Will Smith
has in Men In Black may I ask why you
felt little Tiffany deserve to die I'm
thinking you know eight-year-old white
girl middle of the ghetto a bunch of
monsters this time of night with quantum
physics books she about to start some
said she's about eight years old
those books are way too advanced for her
Olivia Coleman plays Sonja fallsworth of
the MI6 her name fallsworth could make
her related to James Montgomery
fallsworth the British member of the
Howling Commandos in the first Captain
America film MCU did something similar
with Jim morita's grandson being the
principal in Spider-Man homecoming
fallsworth jokes that Fury could have
been the ghost of Paul Robeson referring
to the actor and singer best known for
his rendition of Old Man River from
Showboat Rosen was politically active he
embraced socialism he visited Moscow so
I don't think fallsworth is just talking
about their Blackness but rather a black
man in Moscow specifically fallsworth's
office is lined with clocks all set to a
different hour but at the same minute
her way of knowing what time it is in
each country and fallsworth explains the
old English spymaster that started the
tradition a clock goes up and your time
in the circus is done circus huh well
John Lee Kerry nicknamed the MI6 the
circus because the headquarters were
located at Cambridge circus so
essentially the spymaster would put a
clock up whenever a spy retired or
perhaps died or was killed in action
ballsworth says I still haven't forgiven
you for destroying my very expensive
flat you mean City yes they're referring
to the events of Spider-Man far from
home when Nick Fury was involved with
Mysterio's use of Stark drones that did
quite a bit of damage to London balzer
says that Fury's not knowing about the
Kazakhstan theft and letting her thugs
take him are signs that he's just too
old for this fight when in reality he
went out for a walk knowing that he'd
probably get taken and probably so that
he could bug fallsworth's room he even
tells her that he let them take him so
that he could get to her I think he's
more after this than she thinks in fact
that limp he walks around with may be
performative so that people will
underestimate him outside the scroll
base new skrelos a newcomer named Beto
walks up and delivers the patch phrase
home in my own skin it's not just home
that they're looking for they're looking
for a home where they can walk around
without having to be in Disguise I like
how a sweatshirt looks like a chessboard
chest being a common Motif in this
episode the guard booth sign says the
lesnograd which is a town in Russia with
a developed nuclear industry but it's
not 312 kilometers south of Moscow Gaia
gives Beto a blue squirrel fruit just
another example of squirrel plant life
growing successfully on Earth they are
gradually terraforming it Gaia enters
the room with the humans whose bodies
they've taken so far the second one she
passes is that art dealer that we see
later in the episode and already
bringing up a question I had after
watching this episode why does Gaia need
to pay the scroll a person is at art
dealer for the bomb materials I'm
thinking maybe the money helps them
balance his books and pay the people he
smuggled the bomb parts from the
squirrels bring in the kidnapped AAR
member saying take his face and then
they strap him in saying take his mind
these shells that they keep the humans
in zap their temples to keep them
dormant and to bring their memories to
the Forefront Talos and the other
skrulls use similar memory technology on
Carol Danvers at the beginning of
Captain Marvel but this idea of skrulls
assuming the human's mind is really
interesting concept because it forces
their scroll identities to the back of
their minds and forces them to carry Two
Souls at any given time this idea was
explored in the FX series The Americans
where in later Seasons the Soviet spy
played by Matthew Reeves began to
sincerely adopt American culture and
values and it really just messed with
his head Fury tells Taylor's a bit later
mean well I know a bunch of good looking
squirrels knew anyone okay all right
guys I'm curious to learn what other
relationships with Scrolls Fury might
have did this guy hook up with some
Scrolls I mean he got to know tales and
sword and all their friends just saying
back at new skrillos Gaia reads a book
called understand the human mind a
squirrel trying to use human psychology
against us this is why we should never
publish books about psychology I'm just
kidding graphic loads Cube after cube of
sugar in his drink a villain having a
bit of a sweet tooth is a recurring
Trope we saw this with Han zalanda and a
glorious bastards and father Flynn in
doubt we don't see bravic sipping the
tea maybe the guy's just wasting sugar
because he hates processed human food
Graphics second in command is a scroll
named pagon who from the comic supposed
to scroll that had impersonated Elektra
and the lover to the scroll Queen
varenki he sends guy off with a driver
named xerx Zoo which is the name of his
girl from the 70s Marvel Premiere Comics
who briefly assumed the identity of
Richard Nixon so back to that portrait
of Richard Nixon
let's grow that's no American in the
Modern Age would willfully resign Humans
Ain't That honorable it turns out Gaia
sees an inflatable Russian nesting doll
another example of this idea of people
having other identities inside their
shell Fury reminds Talos that Talos is
136 years old and Taylor says that
equates to less than 40 in human years
meaning that squirrels live somewhere
around 280 Earth years this poses a huge
problem for Earth if the skrulls are
populating the planet rapidly living
such long life spans and consuming
natural resources at roughly the rate as
humans would consume them but with lives
over four times longer than humans live
Earth's ecosystem would collapse unless
the Scrolls put in place population
controls Talus asks Fury what he got for
his midlife crisis shopping spree what
you get for yours The Avengers
yeah Fury considers The Avengers his end
feeling it's also
also in 2012 to be feared Fury of life
is
remember that movie that was only 13
years ago suggesting that he's got a lot
more life he intends to live paverskit
says that the chair of Fury sits and
belonged to Louis XV who is the great
grandson of Louis XIV the great French
absolute monarch in Louis xvii was the
grandfather to Louis XVI who was
executed during the French Revolution
but Fury later mixes it up and calls it
the Louis XIV chair very interestingly
says that everyone gets one and lie but
not two making us wonder what Fury's One
Lie is because otherwise why would he
tolerate a single Lie from others does
he have a family we haven't met yet does
he like to fart on planes Fury shoots
the scroll puppy skin waiting until that
squirrel growls at Talos you betrayed
your own people the Assyrian knows that
when someone says it when someone feels
that way there's no coming back from
that this scroll is motivated to kill
taloso feels horrible that he played a
role in one of his own kind getting
killed Gaia kicks Hill's ass and Talos
has a chance to check in with his
daughter he reveals Soren's death to her
huh
people that you work for
yes graphic was responsible in some way
for sword and death perhaps Soren was in
human form during one of the terrorist
attacks that we saw on the newspaper
board maybe she was trying to protect
the materials that were being stolen or
maybe Soren was trying to get Gaia back
and Grandma killed her for getting too
close at this bar Fury speaks some
Russian with this guy at the bar
and you believe this
interesting that he can speak Russian as
a figure during the Cold War Fury was
stationed in a number of places where
he'd have to use this language Belfast
Bucharest Belgrade Budapest I like the
bees I can make them right but this old
man is another Forum graphic takes at
the end of the episode so this is really
a direct message from graphic to Fury to
make him doubt himself it's just really
creepy to learn how close graphic was to
Fury throughout the episode but never
chooses to strike it's in this moment
where across the bar graphic is
carefully watching Fury and Hill play
chess and that's probably when he
decides to kill Hill and not Fury Fury
says this is how he kept the Cold War
from going high Spooks like
you can't say that no you can't say that
yes that word is considered both the
derogatory term for black people and an
archaic term versus spy Fury probably
means both ways a chessboard separates
them and Hill takes white of course she
does and she does a standard E4 opening
that's where white moves the King's Pawn
two squares up it's the most popular
chess opening as it immediately Stakes
the claim on the center and frees two
pieces the queen and the King's Bishop
for Action what do we see in the open
end of this episode a bishop a queen and
a king Fury asks if Hill is covering her
bases which refers both to their
conversation and her style of play fury
remembers the moment from the blitz for
the post-credit scene of Avengers
Infinity War including hits near F-bomb
well the director Ellie Salim expanded
on this in his interview with us the
blip was a very disorienting thing for
him so I think he really is on his back
foot but the whole show is about can he
regain it or not after asking if I'm
going to delay the strike we think Gaia
is getting cold feet but it's just to
give us false hope ahead of her meeting
with her father she tips off Talos that
there will be three couriers and only
now if I'm looking back on it do we
realize they just came up with three
empty shells of the shell game two
couriers and Gaia herself to occupy the
exact number of people in the others
group Fury Hill and Talos all of this
was a big setup they'd lose these
couriers in the Russian Unity Day
celebration we see some acrobats and
some clowns making this exactly the kind
of circus that fallsworth was referring
to earlier but Fury sees that girl with
the same Rainbow Ball from his night
walk the night before he follows her as
she shape-shifts them to the old man at
the bar that he bought a shot and then
into the woman from the kissing couple
who stared at him and then finally
gravic himself and the fact that graphic
is shape-shifting in plain sight of
everyone else in this Russian Community
Day hangout shows us how little he cares
about being spot that's a scroll because
he knows that bigger fireworks are gonna
happen right in the second anyway he
detonates the bombs and notice how Hill
would have survived but what was she
doing helping someone get to their feet
that's what slowed her down so that fake
Fury could catch up to her
Hills final words to Nick Fury are
while it wasn't Fury directly to pull
the trigger blood remains on his hands
and it hurts him so much to think that
in her dying moments she thinks that she
was betrayed but also we could read this
as Maria Hill warning her old Mentor
that there is a second Nick Fury in the
field he took his eye off the ball and
he refused to make a chess move he
allowed himself to fall three steps
behind and get played so God R.I.P Maria
Hill Kobe smolders you've been great to
us these past 11 years at the MCU we'll
really miss you and I think part of the
reason this episode established that
Soren was dead was to remove any doubt
Hill's known scroll impersonator is gone
too so there's really no chance that
this isn't her here if this series can
kill off Maria Hill someone who's been
with us since 2012. again permanently
change the status of any MCU figure and
little detail in its final shot at Maria
Hill bleeding out beside her is a
dropped Russian flag colors white blue
and red just like the colors of Maria
Hill a white top a blue coat and jeans
and red blood staining it all what an
episode please subscribe subscribe to
the three channels of this network new
rock stars the Deep dive in the break
room support us by grabbing some merch
at nerdriot.shop follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at EA boss follow me
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
foreign